[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel midoro bonsoir
bonsoir alors on commence ses
informations en prenant la direction de
Versailles où un lycée a été évacué
aujourd'hui ce mercredi 15 novembre aux
alentours de 9h45 le lycée mariecury de
Versailles éta évacué en raison d'une
alerte à la bombe l'établissement a reçu
un message d'alerte et les responsables
ont fait retentir la senerie pour
évacuer les lieux l'annexe du lycée a
elle aussi été évacuée les forces de
police et les démineurs ont fouillé les
locaux sans on rien trouvé ces dernières
semaines les alertes à la bombe se
multiplient dans les î vines que ce soit
dans les établissements scolaires ou les
lieux culturels comme le château de
Versailles et après Versailles on va
prendre la direction de poissie des
postes vont être supprimés à stellentis
oui Mathilde l'usine située à poissie va
réduire son personnel le groupement
Automobile International a décidé de
supprimer une équipe de travail sur son
site pisiqueé objectif mettre en place
une nouvelle organisation à partir du 28
novembre une réorganisation qui fait
suite à des problèmes de logistique et
d'approvisionnement des fournisseurs
concernant la fabrication de l'Opel moka
et de la DS3 crossback au total 560
personnes sont concernées par cette
restructuration 200 à 250 intérimaires
ne seront pas conservés selon le groupe
stellantis la production ne baissera pas
et sera maintenu à 12000 voitures par
mois à Montini le Bretonneux vous l'avez
sûrement remarqué d'ailleurs si vous
êtes passé à côté du rond-point du
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
niveline l'arche de Piotre Kowalski est
en travaux construite en
1991 cette arche va connaître un beau
lifting avant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 depuis le 6 novembre les vers
bleu sont retirés petit à petit objectif
les nettoyés surtout les ouvriers
pourront remettre à œuf la structure une
fois terminé un nouvel éclairage sera
mis en service et le bassin sera de
nouveau rempli la fin des travaux est
prévu pour le printemps 2024 coût total
de l'opération 520000 € financé par la
Région le Département 50 ans livvin et
la Direction Régionale des Affaires
Culturelles et enfin Michael vous avez
une dernière information concernant la
BGE yeline le premier réseau national
d'appui aux entrepreneurs lance un appel
à candidature pour la première promotion
de son incubatest après un entretien les
le candidat pour intégrer un parcours
immersif de 6 mois renouvelable lui
permettant notamment de mettre en place
sa stratégie commerciale et de monter en
compétenence à la fin le dirigeant
récupérera son premier chiffre
d'affaires réalisé et continuera à
développer son entreprise si vous voulez
vous inscrire le site à part à l'écran
et bien merci beaucoup Michel el midoro
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news